hey youtubers is Charlie we're almost
there HBO dropped a new preview so let's
break it down this will be a top 10
video just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened so far if
you're just finding me for the first
time or you haven't been around since
season 6 welcome back be sure to
subscribe to get everything and make
sure you turn alerts on so you don't
miss any of the videos they'll be
giveaway stuff happening this season
I'll explain at the end of the video and
I'll also explain my video schedule
because there'll be more stuff happening
before we get episode 1 on Sunday so
because they dropped a bunch of episode
1 stuff let's break this down I'll just
do top 10 style like I'm going to do my
episode videos starting with number 10
Mira and bran make it back to the wall I
love the look on her face hair it's so
priceless like she is just so ready to
be done with this and a lot of you've
been asking me what I think the first
shot of episode 1 is going to be I think
the seasons going to begin and end at
the wall means that one of the first
things we'll see is this moment here
with them crossing blown to Castle black
and then the final moments will be of
something really crazy happening at the
wall we can talk about more end of the
season predictions as we get on but
number 9 in conjunction with that brands
relative state is a human potato
he's the three-eyed Raven and him
returning to Winterfell has huge
implications but it sounds like the way
they're balancing Daenerys his character
like she has ultimate power literally
she is so low-key right now with those
dragons there's only a couple ways the
Lannisters could fight them so brand
being one of those other characters that
has ultimate power to need some balance
so it sounds like the way they did that
is to turn him into something of a human
potato so he can communicate with other
people
mirror is able to speak to him when he's
having his visions but it sounds like
he's going to be spending more and more
of his time in these visions learning
things using his power trying to suss
out what the knight King is doing so
Mira is left to the task of just
dragging him around while he's catatonic
he has so much information that he needs
to convey so I think he'll have moments
of lucidity you see him in the chair
later in the trailer so obviously that
happens when he gets back to Winterfell
but I don't think he's going to be in
any kind of state to be any kind of
leader so like if you saw spider-man
homecoming
Ned leaves is Peter Parker's man in the
chair bran is the ultimate Mei
in the chair he's very literally sitting
in the chair once he does get back to
Winterfell you have that stark reunion
moment oh my god bran you're still alive
but what's happened to you and they sort
of get over that initial meeting he
probably spends most of his time in the
godswood with his hand on the weirwood
using his power but number seven the
look on Ed's face here don't forget that
he's now Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch as appointed by Jon Snow when he
took off my watch is over now their
numbers are down because they executed
all the mutinous brothers last season so
it seems like Mira has a lot of fun
trying to explain what happened last
season what they've been doing north of
the wall
in how the night king is on their
coattails and they need to start getting
ready and he just has this crazy look on
his face when she dumps all this
information on him and I know a lot of
you were looking at her sword hilt here
because it's featured so prominently
there was a fun theory that she might
actually be wielding the Bloodraven
sword dark sister which is one of the
ancient Targaryen Valyrian blade that
was passed down it's very possible but I
don't think you can ascertain that just
from looking at the hilt here but the
important thing to remember about
Valyrian swords because a lot of people
always talk about Longclaw like maybe
Longclaw is actually dark sister because
when the old bear gave long cloth to Jon
Snow he had a new hilt put on it so even
though it's incredibly hard to reforge
Valyrian steel much less make it it's
actually much easier to put a new hilt
on it so you could have a Valyrian sword
and just change the hilt and pass it
from person to person
moving along though number seven
Daenerys lands on Dragonstone foregone
conclusion the title of the episode is
Dragonstone it's 59 minutes long meaning
that I think we're going to hit most of
all the characters there are a few
characters I don't think we'll see which
I'll talk about later but we've seen a
whole bunch of shots of Daenerys riding
up looking at the gates as they open
walking straight up into her throne room
so it seems like that's the first place
that she goes then she makes her way to
the map table room where she starts
thinking about her battle plan in number
six Circe's floor map being painted here
it looks like there's a parallel between
their two storylines in the episode
where Daenerys starts planning her
battle as Cersei starts planning her
battles to the Game of Thrones premiere
was last night they had a big
after-party the dancefloor was
painted to look like the giant map of
Westeros that Cersei has it was really
cool in number five as we've seen a lot
of behind the scenes shots it seems like
Jaime is still with her for at least
most of the first episode before he goes
off and starts leading their army the
relative state of their arcs is really
interesting because as Lena Headey the
actress explains that Jamie is
hopelessly devoted to Cersei at the
beginning of the season but we know
based on the description for episode
three
that he comes to his senses and
something really bad happens because
Lena Headey has been hyping up how
excited she is for Cersei going nuts
this season which is the most terrible
person you could imagine so even though
you have all these characters trying to
tell Jaime that Cersei is horrible and
he needs to be a good person like
Brienne or Tyrion trying to get him to
do the honorable thing but he has
steadfastly remain committed to Cersei
you love who you love but it sounds like
at some point she's going to do
something so bad that he'll say enough
is enough but one of the coolest things
this season I think is seeing the rise
of Jaime is a battle commander so most
of the shots that we see him in are
either with Cersei or riding on the
battlefield leading the Lannister army
you think back to season four how Jamie
was obsessed with the white book doing
something great worthy of having his
deeds honored in the book the way
Barristan Selmy or the other great
Kingsguard had I think Walser seized on
this downward spiral of craziness Jaime
is actually headed on his way up but
obviously you know he already narrated
his own death I want to die in the arms
of someone I love so I will do a death
predictions video in the next couple of
days he's not really high on my list for
this season I think a lot of the big
debts will be pushed to season eight but
number four back up at Winterfell I
think it's also a bit of a metaphor for
how the seasons going to start off up
there with them slowly chasing their
tails fighting each other a little bit
before team Stark comes together and
they have their big payoff but
separately you also see the little bear
looking like she's mouthing off giving
one of her big speeches so it sounds
like they also waste no time in arguing
about what to do next in the wake of the
Battle of the bastards so they still
have to deal with the Karstarks the
umbers the people that were loyal to the
Bolton's what are they going to do with
their territories and what are they
going to do with the wildlings because
while they have named Jon Snow King of
the north and even sought those sort of
Co rule
with him they still don't like the
wildlings that much so they're not going
to be very happy if John tries to grant
them a bunch of land so even though
we've moved past the book plot like we
are in uncharted territory there are a
lot of theories that they might use the
Alice Karstark twist from the books and
it'll be some sort of alliance that's
forged through marriage to one of the
wildlings normally that would be tormund
Giantsbane but he's actually pretty high
on my death predictions list so I don't
know if he's going to be getting married
to anyone anytime soon regardless of the
way it went down in the books but
separately number three it seems like
Littlefinger will waste no time in
putting his grand plan into motion
creating chaos amongst the Starks
he always has a number of plans like he
says toussaint side when he narrates in
the trailer fight every battle
everywhere in your mind at the same time
but then she narrates the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives so you can kind of
see what his arc this season is he's one
of those lone wolves that's going to die
because the pack the stark children are
meant to come together he's also really
high in my death predictions list but a
lot of people ask about his plans I do
think that he's back dealing with Cersei
in case his plans with sanso and the
North fall through he always has
multiple irons in the fire playing all
sides against each other so as much fun
as it'll see to watch him be as devious
as possible what I'm really excited
about is when Aria finally has her big
reunion and he tries to play all of the
stark children against each other and to
see how Jon Snow in Aria deal with that
because it looks like sauce is slowly
getting used to Littlefinger she's been
with him for so long but Aria in Jon
Snow do not suffer fools the same way
that salt has been forced to but number
two what about the army of the Dead all
the night King the white Walker shots
that we've seen look like they've been
from the heat of battle which implies
that they're much later in this season
so just as we've had with previous
seasons it sounds like we'll slowly feel
their presence more and more as we get
deeper into the season I'm expecting
full-time compression to be in effect
north of the wall what'll probably
happen in the south is that you'll see
characters travelling around really fast
between episodes but even though the
night king in the army of the Dead isn't
that far from the wall they're not just
going to walk up and Park it there all
season long
he's waiting for brand to cross with his
mark so that the magical enchantment
will be broken and he can bring the wall
crumbling down all the shots we've seen
to them so far are of people that
haven't made it to the north yet
fighting them north of the wall so I'm
expecting there to be lots of questions
about what the night King was doing for
the first couple of episodes if bran had
already made it south of the wall like
why is he waiting to come bring the wall
crumbling down the big reason I think
will be so that you can end on the
dramatic moment of him either cracking
the wall or bringing a crumbling down
something with him destroying part of
the wall and then them cutting to black
before season 8 because like I said I
think will begin the season and end the
season with scenes at the wall but
number one there's a whole bunch of
characters that we haven't mentioned
here that don't appear in the previews
Samwell Jorah benjin Arya the
Brotherhood so I think that most of
those characters will be in episode one
briefly mostly Arya Stark all the main
characters tend to get preference but
the Brotherhood and Arya are slowly
making their way north separately
Samwell is the Citadel training to
become a maester it does seem like Gilly
based on the previews will be the one
that finds out accidental information
about a Zora hi so you have a lot of
really big mythology that they need to
convey this season to people like Jon
Snow the prince was promised the son of
Liana and Rhaegar so it seems like most
of that information won't get sucked out
until everybody converges in Samwell
makes his way back door but I think that
half of that will come from Samwell
through book learning that he finds out
at the Citadel in brand who's literally
experiencing this in flashbacks but if
anybody is going to save Sir Jorah it's
got to be Samwell which makes you wonder
why the other maesters haven't learned
to cure greyscale better like if Samwell
just shows up in a single season and
suddenly learns how to cure greyscale
then why is it that all these other
maesters haven't learned that yet and if
they do cure Sir George greyscale what
was the point in giving it to him in the
first place anyway so just remember all
those things as those storylines play
out it adds for benjin I don't expect to
see him again until we go back north of
the wall later in the season and he is
also on my death predictions list I
think that anybody that goes north of
the wall is marked for death unless
their name is Jon Snow and Daenerys
so what will happen is my next video
will be my death predictions that will
either post Friday or Saturday but leave
all your bonus video requests in the
comments below my episode 1 video will
post after the episode airs Sunday night
all my episode videos will post right
after the episode there then I'll do
trailer videos on Monday then I'll do
Q&A videos and anything else you guys
want the HBO now giveaway will be
happening every week congratulations to
the latest winner Ryan Springer please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll announce the next winner in
the next video that I post while you
wait for everything click here for the
newest promo and you can click here for
all my season 7 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight